Good morning, Hank, it's Tuesday - it's question Tuesday,
the day that I answer real question from real Nerdfighter.
That's right, no plural today, just the one question.
[Music]
"Hi, I am a fifteen-year-old girl named Katie."
No, you're not. You're John Green, sitting
slightly farther away from the camera.
Right, no, I realize that, but I'm quoting
a fifteen-year-old girl that wrote us an e-mail.
Ohh! Alright.
"I'm not very popular. How do I get boys to like me?"
Thank you for your question, Katie.
Let me begin by acknowledging that I am not an expert
in the field of fifteen-year-old boys.
In fact, Katie, putting aside the question
of how to get boys to like you,
I don't know how to get boys to like me.
Katie, I don't know if you know this, but all of our videos,
except for the ones that feature giraffe sex as the center screenshot,
are watched by nearly three times more women than men.
So, Katie, my first piece of advice to you is that
if you want to get boys to like you,
you should become a giraffe.
(And then, have yourself videotaped getting
your giraffe freak on.)
So, Katie, from what I can tell,
there are about six ways to get fifteen-year-old boys to like you.
The first way is, of course, to become a giraffe.
The second way is to become World of Warcraft.
The third way is to be something called "hot".
Now, Katie, I would argue that there are at
least two distinct definitions of "hot".
There is the, like, normal human definition
which is "that individual seems suitable for mating",
and then there's the weird culturally-constructed
definition of hot, which means
"that individual is malnourished, and has probably
had plastic bags inserted into her breasts".
Now, boys may find that hot now but I don't
think there's anything inherently hot about it;
like I think if you went back to the eighteenth century and you
asked a fifteen-year-old boy, "Would you like to marry a woman who
has plastic bags needlessly inserted into her breasts?",
that 15-year-old boy would probably be like,
"What's plastic?"
The fourth way to get a boy to like you is to be yourself.
Now, I'm contractually obligated as an adult to give that advice,
even though it doesn't work.
But, yeah, "be yourself", even though no one
has any idea what it means to "be yourself".
Like, whose self would I otherwise be being?
The fifth way to get boys to like you is to meet their expectations by acting like you're an idiot.
There's this famous poem by e.e. cummings
that partly goes,
"-the best gesture of my brain is less than
your eyelids' flutter which says
we are for each other",
and, like, nothing against the quality of that lady's eyelid flutter,
but why is it that women's eyelids are always fluttering
while men's brains are always working?
So, yeah, you can buy into the cultural constructions
that young women are supposed to be stupid and awkward and eyelid-fluttery -
which of course, Katie, is totally easy to do because sometimes you feel stupid,
and sometimes you feel awkward,
and sometimes you wanna get all eyelid-fluttery.
But the great secret of boys
which they are right now denying in the comments
of this very Youtube video is that sometimes they feel stupid,
and sometimes they feel awkward,
and sometimes they feel all eyelid-fluttery!
When you realize that all brains gesture,
and all eyelids flutter,
and everybody feels awkward,
boys will like you (because we will be scared
of your knowledge).
The sixth way to get boys to like you: consider
different boys.
Katie, I have two words for you:
nerd boys.
Katie, I know that nerd boys don't sparkle
in the sunshine,
but they're sensitive, they're caring, they're
sweet, they'll do nice stuff for you,
they're a little bit needy - I will grant you that they're a little bit needy.
Oh, and lastly, let me explain  something briefly to boys:
gentlemen, nerd girls are the world's greatest underutilized romantic resource.
And, guys, do not tell me that nerd girls aren't hot,
because that shows a Paris-Hilton-esque failure to understand hotness.
Hank, I'll see you tomorrow!
I'm so excited for song Wednesday, I gotta
do a little dance!
Dance, dance, dance, dance, closing move!